ان وقع الاتفاق بمرافقتي اداره اراده
سياسيه للحل في ليبيا كما تحدث بوريطه هل
بقيه الاعضاء اعضاء المجلسين يوافقون على
هذا الامر لا يبدو ذلك اللجنه تواجه
انتقادات كبيره 60 نائبا في البرلمان
حملوا رئاسه المجلس مسؤوليه التوقيعي او
الموافقه على مخرجات اللجنه دون الرجوع
الى البرلمان اما مجلس الدوله 54 من
اعضائه رفضوا مخرجات اللجنه شككوا في
شرعيتها ودعوا لرفض اي تسريبات بشان
القوانين الانتخابيه كما اعلنوا رفضهم
التعديل الدستوري الثالث عشر
[موسيقى]
العرض الذي طابعناه عن التعديل الدستوريه
الثالث عشر ينقلنا الى سؤال اخر ماذا ان
لم يتوافق الطرفان على قانون الانتخابات
كما تحدثت المصادر سيتم اللجوء للخطط
البديله التي اعلن عنها المبعوث الاموي
لليبيا عبد الله بتيلي بتيلي اصلا انتقد
بشده هذا التعديل الدستوري الذي جاء قبل
احاطته في مجلس الامن في فبراير الماضي
ووجه حديثه لمجلس النواب والدوله
سيختبر الوقت هذا الالتزام العلني الجديد
من مجلس النواب والمجلس الاعلى للدوله
وقادتهم سيكونون مسؤولين عن اقوالهم امام
ليبيا والمجتمع الدولي
المهله التي حددها بتيل من اجل الوصول
والتوصل لاتفاق تنتهي بحلول منتصف يونيو
وقتها سيتم تشكيل لجنه امميه رفيعه
المستوى لاعداد القاعده الدستوريه وقوانين
الانتخابات ستضم اعضاء من مجلس سيء النواب
والدوله بجانب اطراف اخرى فاعله غير ممثله
في المجلسين
من الاهميه بمكان للقاده الليبيين ان
يستجيبوا لهذا النداء الندائي شعبهم
وان
يتجاوز
المصالح الشخصيه
ويتجاوز ايضا المصالح
الفئويه وينظر الى مستقبل ليبيا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات